welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternal's post-credits
scene spoilers ahead revealed what is
really now unavoidable front page news
that harry styles has joined the mcu as
arrow sega a star fox eternal of titan
and brother to thanos and it's that
family link that has most of us a bit
curious because uh visually speaking one
of these things is not like the other
one a smoldering cut of beef arousing
parts of us we didn't know existed and
the other one harry styles but to fully
understand what aeros arrival means for
the eternals the celestials the
asgardians and the rest of the mcu we
must explain his place in marvel's
ever-expanding ancestral genealogy
something aeros may be reluctant to do
because it would give prosecutors access
to his dna but we must do this the mcu
family tree explained horny edition so
we got the eternals icarus ajak thena
fastos gilgamesh cersei kingo markari
sprite and drig all created by the
celestials we actually learn in eternals
that these ten are actually synthetic
beings built and rebooted by arashim in
the world forge in order to allow
intelligent life like humans on earth to
evolve and feed a celestial seed buried
inside the planet repeating the cycle
past eternal groupings have done on
countless planets the deviants were the
celestial's original creations as well
made to clear out native apex predators
on a planet so intelligent life could
thrive so we got those three eternal
deviants and humans and the movie
actually includes a fun hint to this
lineage by giving deviants four eyes a
step down from the six eyes of the
celestials but still a step up from the
two of eternals and humans however these
ten eternals are not the only eternals
in existence because we meet arrows
eternal of titan brother to thanos
confirming that thanos is also an
eternal as he is in the comics but he
possesses a deviant gene that results in
his scarred purple skin in infinity war
red skull greeted thanos as son of allah
meaning thanos and eros come from an
eternal bloodline they are offspring
their mother was sui-san their father
alars and elars's parents were the
eternals cronos in diana who bore both
alars and zuros who was athena's father
so in the comics at least thena and
thanos are first cousins as are athena
and arrows so stop hitting on your
cousin arrows to saint the british royal
family but it seems like the movies are
suggesting there is a difference between
the 10 synthetic eternals in the
eternals film who would not be capable
of producing offspring if the celestials
intended them to be exposable temporary
caretakers a difference between them and
the eternals of titan with a bloodline
of a large thanos and arrows and that
might be because in the comics alars
actually left earth for titan after a
succession dispute with his brother
zoros if the movies were to explore this
history the synthetic versions of theena
icarus cersei and the rest could
actually be carbon copies based on
original eternal forms that were capable
of life cycles in reproduction
alternatively since the eternals despite
their synthetic nature still bleed and
are made up of bone and tissue et cetera
thanos aeros and lars may very well have
been synthetic creations that were
placed by celestials on titan and there
might be no common ancestor of kronos in
the mcu putting an aerosthena hookup
back on the table boys now arrows based
on him having his own sphere either is
or was the prime eternal of titan does
not seem like titan ever underwent an
emergence though the planet and its core
were still clearly intact when we
visited it an infinity war however that
could just be because titan suffered an
ecological disaster that wiped out most
of its population which if a celestial
seed were planted there would deprive
that gestating celestial of the life
force energy needed to hatch now thanos
suggested titanfall due to not enough
resources to go around too many mouths
to feed implying overpopulation but
perhaps titan's population peaked and
fell due to natural resources failing to
keep up before that peak could reach the
critical mass point to hatch the
celestial again we don't know yet if a
sleeping celestial is seated on titan
aeroshem didn't necessarily cede every
planet in existence implied by the shot
of earth already existing before the
seed was sent the titan eternals may
actually have been given a totally
different purpose from totally different
celestials now i gotta tell you
sometimes my eyes get a little numb from
staring at screens this long and all
that activity just makes it really hard
for my eyes and my whole body just to
settle down at nighttime especially
considering no matter how hard you try
it's just so hard to get your bedroom
completely dark at night i got chargers
alarms power strips everywhere it's a
minefield of distracting lights
brightening up my room and making it
harder to fall asleep well that is where
the blue blocks remedy sleep mask comes
in handy thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video we already know
blue blocks from their blue light
blocking glasses but their sleep mask
goes further and blocks that one hundred
percent of light so that you can sleep
better it has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap to give everyone the
perfect fit it works for people who
sleep on their bellies on their sides
and on their backs you can fully open
your eyes while wearing it like my eyes
are open right now does that freak you
out don't worry it should only freak you
out if like you wake up next to me in
your bed and that should freak you out
unless you're my fiance watching this
video but she doesn't watch these videos
so it's just for a gap really it's just
been so great for improving my sleep as
well as like meditation napping travel
you just pop these bad boys on while
flying and you're gonna be doing great
go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars or just
click the link below and get 20 off your
remedy sleep mask today the code is
automatically applied for that 20 off so
all you need to do is click the link
below and enjoy free shipping on orders
over 115 to get the best sleep possible
right now get yourself a blue blocks
remedy sleep mask go to
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com new rockstars or
just click the link below to get 20 off
your order code automatically apply to
check out so the celestial family tree
grows wider of course humanity and
mutant kind branched out but the
prologue of this film confirmed that the
celestials existed before the big bang
suggesting that there was some form of
existence long before that all happened
so to extend the tree further upward we
could go by the updated marble mythology
from the ultimates volume 2 number 6 of
2017 which stated that everything
actually began with something called the
first firmament the very first living
embodiment of the original universe long
before eternity and he created the
aspirants and then they created
multicolored rebels in their own image
whom we know as the celestials everyone
went to war eternity was formed and
within eternity the celestials were left
to run things actually a war with the
aspirants could have been how areshem
got his weathered scarred appearance so
getting back to what purpose arrows
thanos and lars might have had on titan
there was that curious exchange between
gilgamesh and kango that mentioned odin
and thor as contemporaries thor used to
follow me around when he was a little
kid now he's a famous avenger and won't
return my calls so the eternals and the
asgardians knew each other and that's a
huge deal because in the earth x comics
the asgardians are retconned as aliens
that were manipulated by the celestials
who put them in the third tier of the
celestial mutation cycle that makes
their appearance their powers and
identities defined by the belief of the
people they protect in this case the
norwegians of midgard circa 965 a.d so
the asgardians could be yet another
creation by the celestials given an
eternal style protection protocol rivals
like the frost giants the cronins could
be classes of deviants that the
asgardians were tasked with keeping in
check but i just think this tells us all
that there is far more diversity of
philosophy among the celestials and
their different classes of eternals than
air shim would have us believe ereshim
was just one of many celestials who
performed different functions we
actually saw others during the film's
cosmic montage we saw jamiah the
analyzer nazar the calculator and hargan
the measurer we met issa on the searcher
and the first guardians and there are
plenty of others in the pages of comics
with really fun names like oneg the
prober ow
so i think eros might have been
installed on titan by a celestial other
than aeroshim with the goal of spreading
love throughout the universe after all
he is the god of love is he not so what
celestial would be that into love maybe
the only one we've heard talk about his
member yes drax
i got a penis it's not half bad yes eros
could have been installed on titan by
ego before ego had his memory wiped and
was reduced to a floating brain in space
perhaps he was a gestating celestial who
came early i just think there is a
pretty characteristic resemblance
between ego and eros both of them score
pretty high on the dtf meter so if this
were true it would make eros and thanos
something of step brothers to peter
quill and for peter quill to be in love
with his adopted stepnice uh suddenly
this became a woody allen documentary
just looking ahead at the god of love's
next [ __ ] there is one marvel release
with love in the title thor love and
thunder which will feature many of these
characters the asgardians and the
guardians of the galaxy as well as gore
the god butcher whose weapon of the
comics has a history of decapitating the
celestial nowhere so this all seems to
be headed in one horny direction so keep
this problematic family tree handy to
support this channel check out one of
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter ea boss follow me
rockstars and subscribe to new rockstars
for analysis breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you